enthusiasm is uh such a superpower that
most people
could tap into and totally don't for
whatever reason
so i graduated in undergrad and i
dropped out of harvard business okay
gotcha and
you said you studied happiness uh like
what was that like one classic i took a
class called getting rich
and but you know that wasn't like my
major it was just one class
um is that really a class yeah so i
actually i studied
psychology um i i started in a track
called migraine behavior
and then ended up in psychology um and
specifically there was a happiness lab
that dan gilbert was running
where we focused on like how people make
decisions what makes us happy
and basically the headline of the whole
uh you know my whole experience was
we're really bad about making decisions
that make us happy we do things that we
think will make us happy but in fact
like getting the fancy car
doesn't make you happy because then you
have to clean the car or getting a
bigger home out of the city
doesn't you know necessarily make you
happy because then you commute farther
to your work so it's just
really really i think a good perspective
of um it's the little things that really
make us happy i love that you know uh
this is very on topic so
so i remember back in the day there's a
guy who was i think a professor at
harvard named sean anchor is that
somebody who was
yeah that was he was uh he is one of my
teachers sean aiker
um yeah he's wonderful and actually um
his core professor tal benjahar um and
phillip stone were my
my thesis so he gave this ted talk
that's pretty great i still remember it
and i watched this thing like 10 years
ago that's kind of you know some talks
just stick with you
and it was called that i think the
happiness advantage or the sort of
something like that and if i remember
correctly the thesis was
um being happy is actually an advantage
to uh getting great results some people
think about it the other way like if a
great thing happens then i'll be happy
and his advice if i what i remember from
10 years ago was
if i am happy i'll have better results
is that a good
is that am i accurate or am i just
totally misremembering
so the short term is that um in under
extreme duress and extreme stress you
can outperform in the short term
if you're actually very happy and
relaxed and fulfilled
you outperform the long call so when
you're building teams
for long-term success so you know
inspired capital it's a venture fund
uh we have a really unique group of
people that have come together to build
this firm
um and we're trying to build a long-term
fund
and so i'm very focused on let's make
sure we have long-term happiness
because you outperform in the long run
and so um and the other thing is i think
one of the things i learned from sean
and tom my
my professors is um positive energy and
attitude are actually an undervalued
resource
people are very naturally drawn to
people that are positive if you're super
negative over and over
people don't want to be around you they
don't want to work with you they don't
want to show up for you
um and so i think again you know one
thing people always ask me is what would
i tell high schoolers and i'm like
have a good attitude it goes really far
and it's it's part of that point of
happiness is an advantage so is
positivity i always talk about this uh
enthusiasm is sort of in complete under
supply amongst successful people so
you know when you're trying to compete
and you're trying to be successful
you're the wrong person i'm like
the stupidest person
obviously you've bought in on this what
i'm saying is that for most people
or most of the environments i've been
around whether it's like you know
entrepreneurs
investors right now i'm at a bigger
company because my company got acquired
it's like the execs at this company
um in some ways enthusiasm i think
people see it as
um like a low status thing to do it's
like oh you know sort of
um being reserved is somehow more
i don't know prestigious or powerful in
some way
uh and i've gone the complete opposite
direction where i'm i'm overly
enthusiastic
and i i'm like dude i have one tenth of
the skills of all the people that have
been around me
but i've been able to go so far because
i think enthusiasm
is uh such a superpower that most people
could tap into and totally don't for
whatever reason
i i mean i totally uh agree with you um
and beyond not only do i totally agree
with you i also think it's worth saying
that
um it is a skill that
we can all adopt right like just trying
to have a positive outlook is something
you know i can't grow taller
or i can't get better at um you know a
certain trait that i just don't have
trying to be positive and trying to to
to be joyful i think actually it's
something we can all put on it may not
be easy for everybody to do it but it is
possible
sam are you an enthusiastic guy uh
i think i am i think that's why people
like this podcast so
we have a very loyal audience and i
think it's
because people feel as though the sean
and i have a little bit of a contagious
energy and yeah it is it is positivity
or
it's very positive but i i think some of
my co-workers will say that i'm kind of
grumpy
because i i've got to be the bad guy
unfortunately a lot of times
i think you have like an angry
enthusiasm uh you flip
your switch flips from like in extreme
enthusiasm and it's super infectious
to like quickly very angry or grumpy
about something and then you
you switch back sort of effortlessly but
for the people around you they're
probably just getting rocked by it
yeah i uh like maybe you were like this
uh but like i will fight with my
like executives at my company but then
we could just hug it we're good
we're good but i definitely like that um